Earth's oceans they're beautiful
inspiring life-sustaining they also as
you're probably quite aware more or less
screwed in the Seychelles for example
human activities and climate change have
left corals bleached overfishing has
caused fish stocks to plummet
biodiversity is in peril so what can we
do well some form of protection
obviously nature is very resilient when
marine areas are strategically protected
entire ecosystems can bounce back
however creating marine protected areas
isn't easy first we have the issue of
figuring out where to protect this coral
reef overlaps with that international
fishing round intersects with this fish
hatchery everything is interconnected
and marine protection plans must take
into account how one area affects
another then there's the issue of
getting everyone on board coastal
economies often rely on fishing and
tourism if people think they can't do
their work there's no chance of getting
the local buy-in you need for the area
to be successful
marine protected areas must also be
enforced that means the government
itself must be deeply invested in the
plan token support will not cut it and
finally conservation requires money a
lot of it governments in Ireland and
coastal nations may want to protect
their waters but often these nations
have very high debt and can't afford to
prioritize conservation if we rely on
philanthropic dollars alone to fund
marine protection we might get a small
marine protected area here another
little one there but we need more marine
protected areas faster to have lasting
impact so what exactly does smart ocean
conservation look like how do we get the
money
government support and careful planning
that takes into account both local
economies and complex ecosystems we want
to share with you an audacious idea from
the Nature Conservancy it seeks to
address all of these things in one fell
swoop they've realized that debt held by
Island and coastal nations is the very
thing that will enable them to achieve
their conservation goals TNCs idea is to
restructure this debt to generate the
funds
and political will to protect reefs
mangroves and fisheries for example if
you refinance your house to take
advantage of a better interest rate
maybe use the savings to insulate your
attic that's what blue bonds for
conservation do for entire coastal
countries we finance the debt then use
the savings to create marine protected
areas of course sovereign debt
restructuring is more complicated than
that
but you get the basic idea if investors
put in forty million dollars now it can
unlock as much as 1.6 billion for ocean
conservation and this is how the work
gets done step 1 negotiate the deal
a coastal nation commits to protect at
least 30% of its ocean areas in exchange
the Nature Conservancy brings investors
public funders and international
development organizations to a table to
restructure a portion of the nation's
debt leading to low interest rates and
longer repayment periods step 2 create a
marine plan simultaneously the Nature
Conservancy works with marine scientists
government leaders and local
stakeholders to create a detailed
conservation plan that integrates the
needs of the ocean with the needs of the
people step 3 activate for longevity TNC
establishes an independently run
Conservation Trust Fund the savings from
the debt restructure goes into it to
support new marine protected areas the
trust then holds the government
accountable for its commitments insuring
that the blue bonds finance real
protection efforts could this plan work
it already has in 2016 TNC helps create
a national conservation plan in the
Seychelles
TN series structured 22 million dollars
of the government's debt and in exchange
the government agreed to protect 30% of
its marine areas today the Seychelles is
on track to protect 400,000 square
kilometers of ocean that's an area
roughly the size of Germany they say
Shell's is protecting its coral reefs is
replenishing its fisheries it's
improving its resilience to climate
change at the same time it's
strengthening its economy this success
is making other governments take note
many want to be part of this there's an
opportunity to scale this up
dramatically and fast TNC has identified
twenty more nations where such a plan
should be possible but to execute the
needs seed capital and to put in place
local teams who
develop conservation plans work with all
the stakeholders and structure the deals
if they get the support they need over
the next five years they could protect
four million square kilometers of ocean
that's ten Germany's this would increase
the amount of protected areas in all of
the world's oceans by an incredible 15
percent
it would allow vast tracts of the
world's coral reefs to replenish and
give safe harbor to countless species
this would be truly incredible and it's
really just the beginning because there
aren't 20 countries in the world where
this kind of debt conversion would work
there are almost a hundred with this
approach everyone wins
governments local citizens funders and
most importantly our oceans
so in fact we all win Earth's oceans
[Music]